(lively music)
- Having a baby is an
exciting and special time,
but labor can be painful.
And it's important that
you be well-informed
about your options for pain control.
You have many choices for
pain relief during labor,
which include unmedicated methods
such as breathing techniques or massage,
and medicated options such
as IV pain medication,
breathing in nitrous oxide,
or getting an epidural.
The decision is personal,
and you may choose a
combination of methods.
An epidural involves
putting a local anesthetic
or numbing medication like what you get
when you go to the dentist
into the epidural space in your back.
The epidural will deliver
a continuous infusion
of medicine that works
directly on the nerves
in your back and numbs the
lower half of your body
in contrast to systemic medications,
which act on your brain and sedate you.
An epidural acts locally at
the nerves that transmit pain
from the uterus and the vagina.
And since the epidural
medicine works directly
on the nerves in your back,
very little medicine gets
to your baby; and you
can safely breastfeed
after having an epidural.
You can get an epidural at any time
once you've gone into labor.
Typically it'll take about 30 minutes
to get the epidural catheter started,
and then an additional 15 minutes or so
for the medicine to work.
If you have obesity or scoliosis,
it may take slightly longer.
We're not actually gonna
place the catheter today
because the patient here
is not quite at that stage,
but so what we would do at this point
is put a little numbing
medication here in the skin.
One thing that's really
helpful is the positioning
of the spine here, and what we're trying
to get is a curve right down at the base.
So, Christina, if you can just, yeah,
curve over the baby like an angry cat,
and then curve, push once against me here.
That's beautiful.
So the curve, this is the
area that we're trying
to get the curve into to
help separate the bones
of the spine to make the gap bigger
for the catheter to go in.
Okay.
And then we use another needle
to help
get
this
thin, floppy
catheter into place
to drip medication right next
to the nerves coming out of the spine.
During this part you
should only feel pressure,
sometimes a needle or a catheter
may brush against the nerve
and cause a brief electric feeling similar
to when you bang your funny bone,
but nothing more serious than that.
Once the catheter's in
place, we then secure it
with some tape,
up the back,
and over the shoulder
where we can connect it to the medication.
The soft catheter will
then stay in your back
until you deliver your baby
with a constant infusion of medication.
The epidural can also stay in place
and be used in the event that
you need a Cesarean section.
You can expect to slowly
feel your contractions
becoming less intense and shorter,
and your legs may feel weak and heavy
like they've fallen asleep.
You'll also have your
nurse place a catheter
into your bladder after
you've had your epidural.
And many studies have shown
that an epidural does not
significantly slow down labor,
and if it does, it only
increases the second stage
of labor by a few minutes.
And there's no evidence
that epidurals increase the likelihood
of needing a Cesarean section.
Sometimes the epidural
needs some fine tuning,
and one in every 10 women will
need the epidural replaced.
Even with the epidural, you should expect
to feel pelvic pressure, especially
when the baby's head is low,
and you're about to deliver.
And the ability to feel pressure is good
'cause it lets you know
when it's time to push.
An epidural might decrease
your blood pressure,
which might cause you to
have nausea and vomiting,
so you'll be given IV fluids
to try and prevent this.
And your anesthesiologist
will watch your blood pressure
closely after you receive the epidural,
provide treatments if necessary.
You could develop a fever,
or itchiness, shivering,
or experience temporary
soreness at the epidural site,
which may last for several days.
But general back pain is
not caused by epidurals
though it's common after any delivery.
Rarely, around one in a
hundred or 1% of women
will develop a severe headache
called a post-dural puncture headache,
which can last for several
days if not treated.
Serious complications after an epidural,
such as the misplacement of the catheter
into a vein, potentially
causing seizures, is very rare.
A block at a higher level than intended,
requiring intubation and
breathing assistance,
again, very rare.
Serious nerve injury: one
in 20,000 to one in 200,000.
Bleeding: one in 40,000
to one in a million.
Infection: one in 20,000
to one in 200,000.
Or other life-threatening complications
are exceedingly rare.
Staying comfortable is an important part
of a positive birthing experience.
Your anesthesiologist is a
pain-management specialist
who works with your
obstetrician to help you safely
through the birthing process.
Feel free to discuss all
your options for pain control
during delivery with your
obstetrician and anesthesiologist
so that you can make an informed decision.
(lively music)